it comes to multistage events some
events look like they sound like they
would multi-stage this is the real
reason why I wanted this so that I've
agreed here
they sound like that would be multistage
but if you phrase the right you don't
need to think of them as multistage so
here's the question
it's Christmas time whereas you're
sending Christmas cards out he's got 10
friends good begin and came out more
sarcastic minutes you can see the kinds
of cards that he had
they're all in pairs you see that two
Christmas trees two angels or two with
stone - reindeer - with Santa Claus okay
now here's the actual question in such a
scenario what is the probability that
Harry and Helmut get matching cards okay
now the reason I'm highlighting this to
you is there's a couple of different
ways to think about this so I take that
back there's many different ways to
think about it and which way you think
about it will define whether this is
easy or hard for you something pause for
a minute and let you have a go and how
would you spot this question okay the
answer is quite an easy fraction to get
to so I'm not really that interested in
the number what I meet you say is how
are you formulating the question and
then going about solving it can I give
you a couple ministers have a theme to
your any devices how would you even
conceive of this problem
americlean diagrammatically so you can
stop me to get to order a solution two
minutes
come back one of the interesting things
about this is that it's all about this
the way the textbook says it which i
think is a fan way to the strategies
it's kind of a little bit the way that
you tell the problem right the way you
can deceive of the problem this is like
90% or whether this is an easy problem
or a harpoon so I'm going to show you
anyways two ways and it's really you see
because I've already seen three more
here in the room then you hope you can
see what's going on
so here's the first way I've done it I
have thought of this first as a
multi-stage of them
okay and there are two stages that I'm
interested in right what are the two
stages well where's ten friends but I'm
only really interested in Harry and
Helmut do you agree and those are the
two friends of interest so what I've
done is being that I've got two friends
that's kind of whenever I see a
two-stage thing that makes me think can
I use a dot diagram I like diagrams they
help me get all the options have in
front of me in a pretty logical sort of
way okay so he is the skeleton of my dot
diagram I'm gonna call this one off the
front I'll call this one Harry and I'll
call this one now let's do it sideways
I'll call this one a helmet okay now
honey she was I'll be choosing friends
remember choosing cards where you can
think about it by the way what I'm gonna
do is think about these friends like a
fix them in place and then choose a card
for them okay because everyone's gonna
get a car initially but who's you want
enough cards so therefore if I say if I
go up and have a look at the designs
here there are two cosmic Christmas
trees well let's call the mum Christmas
tree
one and Christmas tree - okay I'm
labeling them as different because two
people can't get the same card right so
I want to distinguish them in some way
okay Christmas tree one or two angel one
and two
what am I got here snow one and two rain
do you want to think it's set towards
isn't it
one and two okay so these are the ten
possible cars Harry to get and naturally
helmet has the same sample space to
choose from so I'm going to put all of
these options down the side of the
helmet but and this is one of the
wonderful things about dot diagram the
dot diagram itself helps you work out
what the sample space will be for the
multi stage of it because some of the
squares in my grid which would represent
dots some of them are impossible can you
tell me which of those squares I can't
place a dot get anyone
ah very good the diagonal is kind of a
dud isn't it right because they they
both can't
the First's Christmas tree card right
they can both get Christmas tree cards
but not the same one they both can't get
the second one they both can I get this
card or this card or this cut so I have
a whole bunch of options that have been
knocked down it's that okay now just
because the sizes diagram I would
normally draw dots in all of the valid
options remaining but there's so many
that I'm not going to bother if I hadn't
put the crosses how many squares would
there be in total there will be a
hundred ten by ten yes how many have I
just removed
I don't move ten Oh am i dying so now I
know now that I've sort of fixed up my
diagram I now know that the sample space
the size of that sample space is a
hundred take away those ten that we just
eliminated yeah so there are really
ninety options for the multi stage event
helmet gets card Harriet's card okay
all right now that I know that the
sample space is all that remains is to
work out the favorable outcomes
yeah so for example how in what way
where would it be where they both get a
Christmas tree card have a look yeah
there's the first Christmas tree 61/4
helmet and the second one for Harry but
of course there's another way I can do
that and they could swap guns right
because it doesn't matter which ones
which so those are both good right in
both of those cases those are favorable
outcomes
okay and I can keep on going can't I to
both get angels let's see if you those
are the spots where they're broken into
cards do you see that here's where never
gets no cards they both get reindeer
cards they both get sent cause cards are
you happy with the way that I have
number one reduced the sample space to
be the actual options and number two
identify the favorable men so you okay
with that and then of course it's a lot
more lots missing others not gonna
bother
okay so now I can say what are the
favorable outcomes in this case how many
am I tipped in green I have two to ten
right so the favored outcomes are ten so
therefore my probability will be one
divided by the other I'm getting
out of nine okay now some of you got
quite close to it you've got to be
careful in terms of the way you conceive
of like these none that's hopefully they
have beyond doubt you agree with the way
that I formed it as part of my adopt
diagram is so useful it kind of is its
own argument for where I got these
numbers from there are no other options
I literally not every single one out
okay but I'm gonna go over one step
further and again I under make this up
it's a very helpful way of thinking
about it I can retell this event so that
it is not even a multi-stage of it I can
retell it I can reframe it reword it so
that it's even simpler watch you've got
these are five pairs of cards right five
pairs of cards now do you agree that by
the time let's get back to the original
question
by the time Wednesday's human out all
these cards on you know if it was saying
erin and paul who get the same card it
don't matter if it was those two two
people among these friends will
definitely get the same time and this
one happened five times for each of
these five different designs
does that make sense so I can actually
think at the beginning well there will
be 5 1 2 3 4 5 pairs of cards Christmas
trees angels sir radio etc okay now I'm
not bothering to label and universe to
which pair they are because when you
have a look at the original question
doesn't matter which specific design
they get no we just want them to match
okay now eventually once all the cards
industry that they will be matched up
okay now Harry will be on one of them
you could say helmet easily but I'm just
giving an alphabetical now do I know at
the moment whether that's a Christmas
tree or snow car or a new car no do I
care no it also doesn't matter now there
is one situation and only one situation
if these are the paired up designs in
which helmet will get the same car as
him
right which situation is that when won't
you help me go right now that's the only
space he's got to go right but it might
as rewind
before we wanted that situation at this
time how many different friends do I
have to choose from to get the same card
as Harry there are nine friends left to
choose from in other words the sample
space is out of nine how many of them
those friends are the favorable event
only Helmut
just the one now it takes some thought
and creativity and imagination to
reframe the question in such a way and I
won't pretend to say like oh yes of
course you'll think about very quickly
but my point is just to say don't just
to set the question and the first way
that you think of it and then go ahead
and start working at the probability may
just just pause for a second before you
launch into it and think about is is
there a way that I mean a lot of you
didn't even get to this point dot
diagram just go to Duff diagrams as much
as you possibly can of the two stage
events there's any kind of like a safe
option but if you can push a little
further is there another way that I can
restate what the question is trying to
do often you can land on an even easier
way of staying ability